So let's see if we can
work this through.
In the case of gamma equals 1 and
probability of left is a half and
probability of right is a half.
Turns out it will be nice to solve for
the value function, so let's have
three variables that represent the value
function, one from each of those states.
>From the z state, what happens?
Well, with probability a half, we go
to the right, which ends up giving us
an immediate reward of 0 and then we get
a discounted value of being back in z.
>> Or with a half probability,
we go to the left and
we get a reward of 1 and we're done.
So z is two-thirds.
>> Yeah, so just boring old algebra.
I see, you magically put one-half in
where gamma used to be because gamma is
one-half.
That makes sense.
Okay, fair, fair enough.
>> I thought that would
make things easier.
All right, so z is two-thirds,
and let's work out x and y.
>> Okay, so
I guess you will do a similar thing.
>> Yeah, so the value at x from x with
probability a half, we go to the left
which gets us a 0 reward, and then
a discounted value of being back in x.
Or with probability a half,
we get no reward, and
then we have a discounted
value being in y.
Meanwhile y, the value from y is,
well, with probability a half,
we get the discounted
value of being in x.
And with probability a half, we get
a value of 1, and then we're done.
>> That's two equations and
two unknowns.
>> Yes, linear equations.
>> That's even better.
>> So convenient.
>> Cool.
>> And
some normal algebra-ish
kind of things later,
I have x is two-elevenths and
y is six-elevenths, better to be in y.
So when we average our discounted
expected reward from each of
these possible starting states, we get
a third of this and a third of that and
a third or 0.4646 as our value for
taking this stochastic policy.
>> That's not even 50/50, ha.
>> [LAUGH] Okay, and
we said that we could do better.
So, we said we could do better by
choosing probability of left to
be a third and probability of
right being two-thirds, right?
>> Yeah.
>> All right, so
let's see if that actually
gives us a better number.
>> Okay.
>> So we need to work out
what the value of z is in this case
where we're going two-thirds, one-third.
So once we solve through for
z we find out that z is a half.
Before, z was two-thirds and so we
actually are doing worse in this state
because we're spending more of our time
bashing against the wall to the right.
>> Yeah, that's cool.
>> And we're going to write down what
happens from these other two states.
So the value at x which simplifies to 5x
= 2y, and the value of y, because again
we're going to go to the left one-third
of the time, getting us the value at x.
And we're going to go to the right
two-thirds of the time getting us our
value of 1.
All right, so
once we solve all that through, we get y
is five-sevenths and x is two-sevenths.
And so when we averaged these
three values out, we actually get
a half which is a little surprising to
me that those 7s kind of cancel out,
but a half is bigger than 0.464646,
so we actually have a better policy.
>> Right, and
coincidentally it does give us 50/50.
>> What do you mean it gives us 50\50?
>> Well, you said you wanted to do
better than 50/50, 0.5 that's 50/50.
>> No, no, no.
The 50/50 policy which gets us 0.464646,
we did better than that policy by trying
a different policy
that actually gets 0.5.
>> I know Michael,
I was using word play.
>> Brilliant.
>> Thank you, so
I suppose using all of that algebra,
we could actually figure out what
the optimal numbers are if they
aren't one-third, two-thirds.
Maybe they are,
just by replacing all the one-thirds and
the two-thirds with P and 1- P.
Then we'd figure out what P is.
>> Yeah.
>> And I'm sure that would
be a wonderful exercise for
the students to do.
>> All right so,
we'll leave it for that then.
>> Excellent.